jumanji now yeah with uh my man uh
dwayne johnson the royal wayne and rock
just
love him yes yes we love him we love you
you're just good good good people and
then i'm i'm so much better than him
that's not let's not say that that's not
good not like in a way where we're
competing but if we were i would be
better
uh we had dre's it's going to be [ __ ]
amazing
uh duane get out my [ __ ] comment
section
go do something man you know what i got
something for your ass
i got something for you i asked do it
again do it again and i'ma click on you
and i'll click on you and let the people
see how you look during the daytime
news flash dewayne's forehead isn't real
it's it's a prosthetic
dwayne rock johnson has a prosthetic
forehead
it's not real he can take it off it's
like velcro
if you see what's up under there you'll
see what wrestling to do to you
it's not good for your forehead
[Laughter]
the rock has tiny muscles awful question
i think i got it
you think you go there i got a sandbag
now yeah you say that the
the rock has a tiny buttocks
yeah it looks like it looks like a long
breast like a long
succulent like with the areola right on
my forehead there you go there's right
in your foot you got a nipple head
that's [ __ ] up
you guys don't encourage him okay
the rock has tiny muscles
the rock has did he say butthole
tiny [ __ ]
shoot central intelligence i'm
that's right don't forget you gotta say
the question so they know what you're
talking about
what do you say it like that for like
why are you angry all right you forget
all the time
why shouldn't you just be nice what are
you doing did he not take his medicine
i'm on edge baby i ain't had my coffee
but sensitive times everybody don't
laugh like that don't
whoa that's okay well there's my picture
what just happened what do you do
what don't laugh like that you look like
a detective that's a dj
[Laughter]
dwayne johnson don't say it breath
smells like [ __ ] on the regular
nobody knows this you all know where the
eyebrow raise came from
it came from the reaction of people when
he goes hello
and everybody that's what the rock is
cooking
shitty bread okay don't encourage him
all right i'm an expert at this you're
not you're not really
what do you say like that for wait a
minute what's up
is that ladies what's what's going on
there is that's an amazing hat dude
reese jordy bravo first of all
when i look at this picture the first
thing i say is thank god he's bald
hey thank god my name is dwayne
the rock johnson
uh known as the champ um
here doing
here doing some interviews uh and i'll
be interviewing
kevin hart
this one goes to all the co-stars that
i've had except the rock
because he hasn't helped me he hasn't
helped me
at all you've actually listened my
talent it's it's went down
since you've been in my life all right
look sometimes
well oftentimes things get intense here
in the iron paradise but
we ain't playing tiddlywinks and we
ain't reciting nursery rhymes
all right you get lumped up every once
in a while and things happen
that's good that's real good back to
work what up world
i just got done doing session number two
in the gym
sometimes when you clanging and banging
[ __ ] happens
wait get to getting thrown and sometimes
you wake up with a little knot hey
dwayne you ain't the only one getting
hit in the head
with 45 pound dumbbells and 45 pound
plates
because i am too hard work
granted i'm a little dizzy
might have a concussion but they ain't
got a [ __ ] thing to do with my
motive
i'm be honest i ain't feeling too good
i gotta tell you something man i'm
getting tired of this [ __ ] [ __ ] you in
your video
there you go you know my man hey whoever
oh yeah people can can bite that okay
five million people are gonna whip the
[ __ ] out of you
55 million people to [ __ ] off all right
so basically you better watch your
[ __ ] mouth right now how do you cuss
so much [ __ ] have some respect for the
women here
sorry ladies and gentlemen you got a
foul mouth okay i'm saying
my fans don't need to hear that because
we're better than your people
let me talk to you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do me a favor dj let me i just want to i
want to say something real quick no you
could say
well let me say my thing first well give
me before you i know but listen before
you go into that
give me a second because i want to i'm
not a point just let me say
here's the thing we're not dj please
danny glover is who he should be that's
who we should be
well you know what why don't you get
your muscle back out my
danny hey danny can you do me a favor
danny can you stop
danny danny can you stop it can you stop
it
don't you talk to my daddy like that
don't talk to me all right
let me talk to my danny hey danny danny
real quick hey will you shut up danny
glover
i don't danny tell him how different hey
danny put your phone down [ __ ] finish
my video
i'm yelling at my danny you ain't even
in my danish video
me and danny glover are so excited about
what you're about to do
then wait okay listen that's it that's
enough
that's right that's right we're so
excited
get ready everybody